this is Startalk so before we went to
the break we had a cliffhanger that was
given to us by Pete from Twitter and
Pete wanted to know he says here in
California I'm very concerned about the
drought can GMOs make for less h2o
consumption yeah that's that's a big
claim that i think is well substantiated
by the genetically modified company's
genetically modifying companies people
that companies that put jeans from
different species into farms and species
that we want to farm crops especially
okay and this seems they claim very
reasonable that they can make crops that
are drought-tolerant drought tolerant
they can hold their water they don't let
it evaporate through their leaves the
lower stems the way NAT our way extant
native plants might and they strongly
believe that they can reduce the amount
of water needed furthermore it's very
reasonable that we can put so water
capturing gels in the soil in Farm soil
okay and these would be though you know
the you put the foam rubber thing in the
glass and it becomes against organic
growth and be like that in the Farm soil
and you can say well that's not natural
well farming is not natural so using
less water doing more with less choice
that's the key to our future is more
with less not to just do less I grew up
with earth day and the hippies we're all
telling us you know don't drive drive
less breathe less right use less clean
water in fact if you can't don't eat if
you can manage that what I even eat they
certainly didn't bathe with so wear
dirty clothes its water to clean up yeah
so that turned out not the eating part
especially turned out not to be popular
so now the key is not to just do less
it's to do more with less and that is
the claim of the genetically modified
seed companies that they are doing more
with less and I I agree with them okay
I'm not in the business but I agree with
them so there you go Pete the the
drought what
they call it now drought drought
tolerant throughout own drought tolerant
plants especially let's say it rains for
a little while like a cactus it holds on
to its water yes and then it did through
a drought dastard that let's say we're
turning cotton plants into cacti I'm
saying an example that you're all
familiar with this is Startalk